wir beobachten eine
druck im rahmen des gesamten kampagne
die manche westliche politiker
bezeichnete es als einen totalen krieg
gegen russland bei dem jede mittel gut
ist ich möchte vermerken dass das nicht
jetzt begonnen hat die letzten zehn
jahre hat die europäische union im
rahmen ihrer beziehungen mit staaten die
den beitritt zur eu anstreben versucht
von diesen staaten und die serben wissen
dass bestens anschluss an alle
außenpolitische initiativen und die
außenpolitische initiativen der
europäischen union haben immer stärker
in der letzten zeit den antirussischen
charakter und das hat jetzt nichts mehr
zu tun mit dem einheitlichen
wirtschaftsraum mit der einführung des
rechtes das ist eine ausschließlich
ideologisierte herangehensweise die
darauf gerichtet ist den druck auf
russland zu verstärken um deren
selbstständigkeit auf der
internationalen arena zu unterdrücken
und sie denn so genannten werten zu
unterwerfen die europa bereits jetzt
einführt entgegen der eigenen
christlichen wurzeln ich möchte mich
erinnern dass als noch die verfassung
der eu geschrieben wurde man
verabschiedete dieser verfassung nicht
da dessen kann der lissabonner vertrag
aber in der ersten fassung da begann die
verfassung dass europa christliche
wurzeln hat aber die europäischen
granden haben sich geweigert diese
feststellung zu bestätigen die haben auf
diese weise die eigene herkunft und die
eigene religiöse tradition
durchgestrichen und deshalb hat man auch
keinen anspruch darauf dass sie auch die
anderen glaubensbekenntnisse akzeptieren
wir sehen solche druck auf die balkan
länder ausgeübt wird druck auf serbien
ausgeübt wird im rahmen des anschlusses
an die einst russischen sanktionen
sanktionen die praktisch alle bereiche
der wirtschaft kultur politischen und
humanitären tätigkeit umfassen und
darüber sprach ausführlich der präsident
von serien alexander wetzig einige male
als er öffentlich auftrat und betonte
dass serbien sich durch die eigenen
interessen leiten lassen wird solche
länder gibt es nicht wenige bei der u
ich möchte mich erinnern an den auftritt
vor kurzem des premierministers von
ungarn viktor orban der behauptete dass
ungarn die eigenen interessen
verteidigen wird aber diese
multinationaler bürokratie die sich
selbst reproduziert und sich in brüssel
befindet versucht sich selbst alle
staaten ohne ausnahme zu unterwerfen
versucht alle aktion alle bemühungen bei
der feststellung der normen im stab
quartierte eu zu konzentrieren so dass
die eu staaten nach
möglichkeit nicht selbstständig handeln
können und ich bin der meinung dass
diese linie schädlich ist und die
demonstriert noch meist das im wesen
eigenen wesen die europäische union eine
bestimmte denn denn zur stärkung der
autokratie in der person von thompson in
bezug auf alle anderen eu staaten
verfolgt und als in diesen sanktions
krieg auch die von ihnen erwähnten war
dann starten unter negro nord mazedonien
einbezogen wurden schauen sie mal sie
wurden mit versprechungen
einbezogen dass sie schnell sich an die
eu näher kommen aber das passierte nicht
sie wurden in die nato einbezogen
sie wurden ihnen einzige russische
kampagnen einbezogen und man hat die an
die schulter geklopft und wurde besagt
gut gemacht macht
es ist eigentlich nicht gebührt die
entscheidungen zu kommentieren die von
serbien von der syrischen führung vom
serbischen volk getroffen wird hier sind
echte bruder volker uns verbindet die
gemeinsame geschichte gemeinsame siege
gegen gemeinsame feinde und wir fühlen
wie tief diese gefühle verwurzelt sind
im in der seele des serbischen volkes in
seinem historischen gedächtnis und hier
beobachten dass auch heute ich möchte
zurück kommen zu dem was ich früher
gesagt haben wir drängen niemals
jemanden mit gewalt auf und der westen
versucht sehr in die eigene interessen
die eigene linie neben mit gewalt
aufzudrängen mit den wirtschaftlichen
druck mit der bedrohungen erpressungen
mit ultimaten in bezug darauf wenn ihr
der eu beitreten wollen dann müssen sie
die antirussische linie einnehmen das
ist unanständig man darf sich nicht so
benehmen weder in der gesellschaft noch
zu hause noch mit freunden und erst
recht nicht auf der internationalen
arena wo man versucht allen die arme zu
brechen präsident hu jia sich viele male
an dieses thema gewandt und er sagte
ehrlich dass die dass die serben und
serbien ein kleines land ist aber die
serben haben den algen stolz und die
eigenen interesse man versucht diese
interessen wegzuschieben und man
versucht euch so erzeugte politik des
westens zu machen so wir das mit nord
mazedonien mit montenegro geschah wie
man versucht mit bosnien und herzegowina
zu machen deshalb ich kann eins zu sagen
wir respektieren doch das serbische volk
und seine
seine haltung an die eigene tradition an
die eigene geschichte an die eigene
historischen freunde und ich bin sicher
dass das serbische volk auch weiter
hinweise wahl treffen wird ihnen jeder
situation und wird sich immer von den
eigenen interessen leiten lassen